[Music]
hello we
are and this is our favorite snacks
[Music]
yay
oh
yes
spicy
crackers who is he who is he my favorite
snack is
B just so
spicy here we try
[Music]
yeah
oh he tried to film The CF of this snack
I I want it call back please but this is
not too much
spicy cuz in our song we have the lyrics
about
spicy
[Music]
yeah it hello I'm spicy shrimp
bye oh
y I love it
Nutella is is I love it this this is my
favorite your favorite H's favorite
what's your favorite Point really
expensive in
Korea I love I love this snack because
like when we're trowing Nutella is
everywhere yes Nutella is everywhere I
eat so many Nutella all around the world
let's Gog but this Nutella and go the
stick and Nutella is the best
combination so that's why I choose this
one Nutella just delicious oh yeah big
size this is Korean potato potato chips
this snack is you know's favorite
snack
[Music]
I agree sometimes we get some homesick
we search in the Korean restaurant and
kind of this snake make us feel more
comfortable before the show or like that
after show and these days we can find
Korean food or Korean snakes all around
the world very easily oh this is banana
milk man
hey it's good really love
[Music]
it who's favorite IR
Sho when I have a training
student when I practice Boker and dance
and after uh drink
mil it is my energy and do you guys know
this is really delicious after the sauna
really really tasty so so tasty this
friend banana milk had really long
history my father doing this to this
shade is the original it's iconic yeah
so
famous
let's I like it oh love
it and it's really really expensive in
Korea
too but this my favorite snacks yeah but
this important thing is just like this
yeah I know I know I know yeah this
let's
go
okay the chocolates are there but
important thing is I bite the chocolate
around like this and eat like snack same
that that's the step of science version
it is really really so so
tasty take out take out our let's
go telling your soul food his name is
coffee peanut his flavor is so sweet and
and
sweet it's not it doesn't have the T
Taste of coffee oh
[Music]
really yes
wow
yeah this is expensive
chocolate yeah but it's really really I
know who is this who is Young and Rich
who is
he
[Music]
they are our
liar
thank you for watching us share our
favorite snacks and please make sure to
check our new album
yay
90 thank you so much thank you thank
[Music]
you
w